new Joanne Joanne albums for red carpet
mascot and is without any doubt the
greatest album ever made in rock and
roll history I doubt however breakaway
for us the first things off the album
was co-written with Justin Timberlake
they've given the sound and no back to
the groove factor but it's not very much
at you right now or I learned to enjoy
what you're doing because it may never
be repeated we lost a guitar player
halfway through the making of it I would
urge you all to buy it tomorrow listen
to the out when it comes out and if you
don't well stump download it quick I
like this chunky cardigan I love the
suit great civilized it's probably this
jacket let's play clash in turn his name
it's something I wouldn't for probably
1983 Chloe in the seventh is how do you
good good stones how'd you do good on
the Streisand how'd you go good shut up
we work with the people who want to work
with I like Amy Winehouse a moment I
just like at the last thing she needs is
a collaboration sheep he's sent to look
after me
I don't actually have an ipod I actually
don't have an iPod may shock some of the
new out market fire album Tegan and Sara
it's in black down I was listening to
stock house Led Zeppelin Neil Young the
cure Patti Smith losing the Banshees
hands forward by do read classical music
to be honest that disappointed if it
wasn't in the entertainment industry
what would I do something in the art so
just be a clown I have no idea what you
want to do commercial Madison Avenue
advertising captain underpants I don't
think anybody else would have me I don't
know that it is all that different
really h track cartridges still existed
when we began when we did it there's a
guy there he's in these the head of a
and I you looked after and ran he chose
what record went to the radio because
it's the one he liked the most now I
thinking you haven't had a hit record by
the second single you know you drop in
the company oh my god it's quite a long
story favorites are usually the ones
that dress up in special athletes it's
okay to give a long story teachers took
her clothes off and she jumps on the
windscreen of the car swooning and
fainting wrapped herself around the
entirely naked and as this guy's driving
off now it was with the wife and kids
there's a girl hanging on the on the
wipers it was most embarrassing and I
say just keep driving the shortfall off
go with a full story on Joanne Joanne
and more videos go to details com
start again